deux opérations policières ont forcé le
confinement des élèves dans deux sujets
aujourd'hui d'abord à celui de
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu ce matin
heureusement sans conséquence et ce soir
au Collège Montmorency à Laval ou 4
personnes ont été blessées par balle la
fusillade s'est produite à l'extérieur
de l'établissement en début de soirée et
a dit les élèves sont toujours confinés
sont confinés à l'intérieur du Collège
Montmorency je rappelle que tout a
commencé vers 17h30 des coups de feu ont
été entendus des personnes blessées ont
été aperçues et aussitôt important
déploiement policiers qui s'est rendu
ici sur le terrain du Collège
Montmorency je le rappelle la fusillade
n'a pas eu lieu à l'intérieur de l'école
mais plutôt à l'extérieur à proximité
mais ce sont les personnes atteignent
par balles qui pour se réfugier réfugier
ont trouvé refuge dans le collège alors
vous comprendrez pourquoi ça va créer ce
vent de panique sur le campus du Cégep
il y avait plusieurs parents qui étaient
là au cours de la soirée des parents par
Diesel voire même quelques centaines qui
se sont rendus sur les lieux évidemment
inquiets en apprenant cette affaire les
parents qui ont été rassurés ce soir par
les policiers et tout le défi aura été
le suivant dire aux parents tout est
sous contrôle l’intérieur de l'école
mais tout de même on le prend aucune
chance on doit vérifier et contre
vérifier chaque recoin je laisse
entendre quelque part un qui on a parlé
ce soir
c'est ma fille qui est à l'intérieur
on sait parler elle est bien et qu'il
est dans sale avec d'autres amis mais on
sait pas plus de ça j'ai pas j'ai pas de
détails je trouve ça stressant de pas en
avoir
tout ce que je souhaite c'est que tout
le monde est correct à l'intérieur
dit la police est toujours à la
recherche de l'auteur de la fusillade
pour l'instant l'identité des victimes
tout comme ignore les motifs qui ont
conduit à cette fusillade mais on a
toujours pas localisé ni
identifier de suspect on contrait au
moins un suspect selon la porte-parole
service de police nous pourquoi les
chiens pisteurs sont là d'où pourquoi
les policiers sont nombreux sur le
terrain écoutons la porte parole de
service de police
présentement on est en train de faire
des vérifications à l'intérieur du
Collège Montmorency et c'est pour ça que
par mesure de précaution on a décidé on
a demandé aux élèves de rester confinés
dans leur classe il faut comprendre
qu'il faut éviter le plus possible de
mouvement et de contamination de la sein
évidemment qu'on demande aux citoyens du
secteur aussi aperçoit un individu qui
est armé ou un individu qui est louche
qui se trouve dans leur courbe de pas
hésité à faire le 91 puis de nous
contacter
je vous dis à Closer en terminant que la
police vient de déployer son poste de
commandement sur le terrain de l'école
il se trouve à l'arrière de la façade
principale donc évidemment une enquête
qui ne fait que commencer dans ce
dossier merci beaucoup a dit